let's talk about the nine unexpected
benefits of hydrogen peroxide now most
people use hydrogen peroxide to
disinfect a wound after they have some
type of cut and they'll put a little
bandaid on it but there's some other
benefits that actually might surprise
you and you might want to use now what
is hydrogen peroxide it's h2o2 and it's
made out of water and oxygen and it's
one of the safest natural disinfectants
around and your body makes hydrogen
peroxide
your immune systems make it as a defense
mechanism your lung makes it your
thyroid makes it and even your gut makes
it and it's in certain foods like it's
in instant coffee it's in green tea it's
in black tea but today i'm going to show
you some interesting ways to
use this very very inexpensive like home
remedy you want to make sure you get to
three percent you don't want to get like
10 or 20 percent get the 3
all right number one it can help clean
your ears
it can help kill the bacteria in your
ears as well as soften and dissolve ear
wax so you might want to use this
several times a year to clean the wax
out of your ears so you can hear better
so what you want to do is you lay on
your side
with your ear up and then what you do is
you put a couple drops in your ear
okay with a little dropper
and then you take this little flap this
little piece of skin it's like a
cartilage and you press that in and you
pump it like 10 times to kind of get in
there and really wash things up it's
like a little wash machine when you
press this little button right here
and then after about a minute
sit back up
and then you get a q-tip and clean it
out and you're going to pull a lot of
wax out of your ear all right that's
number one number two you can use it to
kill off any type of fungus on your
nails on your hands
or
on your toenails as an athlete's foot
hydrogen peroxide kills hundreds of
different fungi not to mention bacteria
and other microorganisms now with
athlete's foot you might want to add
some iodine and i have a whole protocol
that i will put in the description down
below all right now what about a sore
throat works great what you want to do
is you want to gargle about one
tablespoon and about three ounces of
water
and
this hydrogen peroxide will go in the
back of your throat and actually kill
bacteria and other microbes that
shouldn't be there all right number five
acne there is definitely a component of
acne that is not just hormonal it's
bacteria so you can take a q-tip or a
cotton ball and just dab a little
hydrogen peroxide on acne and actually
it will help shrink the acne or at least
handle the bacteria irritation
inflammation with your acne all right
number six it's a wonderful mold and
mildew cleaner for your shower for this
you just want to use straight three
percent hydrogen peroxide you put it in
a little spray bottle spray the mold and
then leave it for 30 minutes and then
rinse all right number seven you can use
it to remove stains like wine
blood and grass stains all right number
eight you can use it for plant fungus so
if you have a garden and there's some
fungus starting to grow you can put four
tablespoons in a pint of water and a
little spray bottle spray the leaves
twice a week and you'll find the fungus
start going away because hydrogen
peroxide is really really especially
good for mold and fungus all right
number nine you can use it as a
vegetable wash
which will actually help you preserve
the vegetables and also clean some of
the pesticides and any type of pathogens
that might be existing on your
vegetables so what you want to do is you
want to put a fourth of a cup in a
gallon of water and then let your
vegetables soak for about 20 minutes
take them out rinse them out dry them
and you're good to go now if you haven't
seen my video on baking soda you have to
check that one out i put it right here
you